行くようにしてるんだけど今年はあの 向こうが来てくれちゃったんだから
どうしようかなという話したところです 行ったほうがいいですよ
行けそう
モロヘイヤのスープ
おいしそう
モロヘイヤのスープ良かったら おかわりしてください
あと7分したらダザニアを出しますので
超で良かった倉田さんの馬のね 個展の時にヤスコさん来てくれて
すごく良かったですね
もうびっくりした
昔あの湯沙さんってすごいね馬術家がいたんですよね
その方を知ってられるからびっくりしました
そうなんか共通のお世代がいっぱいいらっしゃってね
本当ですか
馬術界の中では湯沙さんとか木戸さんとか西田行って金メダルを取った人とかね
あの世代の人が最初の馬術の
木戸先生も何かおとりになったんですよね
そうですよね
はい
あと
あとインナミ清さんっていう方とね
小松崎先生と何も何か共通の次第に
僕が馬術書として知ってる人たちなんですよ
インナミ先生とかの本とか一生懸命読んで
勉強をしました
えーそうなんだ
今でも持ってますよ本を
うん
湯沙さんの
まあそうですね
ちゃんと勉強はしてないと思います
昔の
あの
馬術書っていうと
その
やっぱり湯沙さんとか
うん
そういう人たちが残したのを読んで一生懸命勉強して
わーすごい
ちょっと出まそう
ないよこれ
結構馬術ってこう
伝承っていうか
昔からやってきた人たちの
言葉は違いますけど
うん
すごい参考になりますよね
昔の人はやっぱり
相当乗ってましたからね
なんか人間知らない
いや
人をリアルに知ってるって
リアルにお伝えされてるから
それは大変なことなんですよ
僕たちからすると
そうなんです
だって
ねえ
そんな方に教えていただけないから
そういうチャンスは絶対ないんですよ
私の父親のおかげでございます
パパがねやっぱり
あの
宮内庁のことをやってたし
いろいろなことがあったから
そうじゃなかったらやっぱり
ダメでしたよね
最初に